today infinity Jackson
she has an 80% approval rating and if an
account on Instagram series highlights
particularly competitive teens take me
back to your high school days were you
running for student body were you super
competitive as well I went to an arts
high school that was like it felt like I
was in Fame like all the you know
theater kids were crying in the bathroom
and the dancers really not eating and
the visual artists were doing drugs it
was not like there was I don't even
think there was a student but there was
no not a semblance of school present or
anything so no I I didn't have that any
of that experience at my school no I I
didn't either but for other reasons
wanna delve into that no okay I mean I
just you know I wasn't involved in that
area of of school we were watching the
show we noticed a lot of similarities to
a lot of real-life story lines that are
going on right now your storyline kind
of reminded us a little bit of the Gypsy
Rose Blanchard storyline had you been
familiar with that in the politician
there are a lot of real-life stories and
issues like voter turnout and gun
control and complicated relationships
between grandmothers and granddaughters
but these are fictional characters in a
fictional reality and I think that's
employments comedy yeah we have to
remember that yeah we're not approaching
it as you know there's a lot of humor to
it even though it's very dark humor but
I think that sets it apart from a lot of
these I mean for instance with that
storyline it's yeah it's horrendous as
it is I think there's humor in it so
evidently there's a videotape with some
footage of you using an offensive gay
slur do you have any idea what I might
be referring to you have any idea what
comment is shut up man I'm not gonna
take your [ __ ] tonight okay what did
you say on the tape she said butt munch
she called an obviously gay reporter
butt munch dammit this is all over now
goodness gracious you two are playing
one mesmerizingly messed up grandma
granddaughter duo
thank you how does it two of you bond in
order to bring that on-screen connection
to life I mean you know when you get
into these things you have no rehearsal
time we'd never work together we'd never
really even met before we started
shooting I don't know there's just
sometimes you get lucky you know
sometimes there's just a chemistry there
and you immediately like the other
person and then I mean and it was the
stuff we had to do was well-written so
we didn't have to struggle with that I
don't think I really got to dive right
in son I think that is helpful instead
of like slowly there's something fun
about just going right into it yeah
screaming at each other shoving her
brother sticks in the mouths and course
it was a lot of humor and that you know
makes it easier right away I feel like
I'll never be able to look at an Olive
Garden the same nor should you don't
understand why calling that gay man a
buttmunch such a scandal that's what
these do munch butts and celebrate
Halloween the series is filled with so
many powerhouse women yourselves
included we also had the lovely Gweneth
Paltrow were any of you ladies able to
bond together on set I only worked with
her I mean I didn't see anybody else the
entire time I'd come in for like a day
or two you know every couple weeks and
you met each other no she's the only
person I've ever met ever I know no one
else I mean I had a few scenes other
than with my darling here but yeah I I
was not part of the of the main plot you
were able to share so many scenes with a
living legend what lessons we hope to
learn from Jessica she's spectacular and
really one of the funny I mean I mean
one of the most psychotically funny
people that have ever watched up a CEO
there I don't know if you remember the
scene with the Bologna Bologna cups the
half of that scene actually didn't make
it into the show because Ben and I were
crying laughing the entire
rue was probably right and I don't even
all you were all she did was explained
how the Bologna cups from made in like a
sense that not in no cuz there couldn't
cut it because we were all they were
great and we screwed everything up but
just I mean unbearably funny I just yeah
really think I should kill what yes yes
I do
[Applause]
[Music]